et avec nous pour ce club Pierre Jacques
main bonjour Pierre merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous avec ton chef de
politicien Nicolas priscède bonjour
Nicolas fondateur et directeur
Steve nous a rejoint évidemment
rebonjour club entièrement consacré à la
réforme des retraites très agitée au
Sénat autour de l'article 7 sur le
report de l'âge de départ la droite a
accélérer les débats provoquant la
colère de la gauche qui a quitté
l'hémicycle si l'on verra les temps
forts de la séance avec vous articles 7
examinez à l'issue d'une journée de
mobilisation suivie la plus importante
depuis le début du mouvement mais pour
quelle utilité ce sera le débat le
gouvernement reste un flexible et
syndicat demande à être reçu en urgence
par Emmanuel Macron avant de débattre
avec vous on va voir comment s'est passé
la mobilisation dans nos régions
et c'était donc la 6e journée de
mobilisation un million 280 mille
manifestants selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur 3,5 millions selon la CGT on
va voir comment ça s'est passé dans nos
régions on sera à Tours dans quelques
instants mais d'abord direction Toulouse
on retrouve Éric berger rédacteur en
chef adjoint à la Dépêche du Midi
bonjour Eric merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous alors à Toulouse la journée de
mobilisation n'a pas faibli il y a
oui bonjour Oriane effectivement vous
avez donné le chiffre les syndicats ont
annoncé 120 000 manifestants dans les
rues de la ville rose c'est tout
simplement la plus forte mobilisation
depuis le début du mouvement de
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites alors chiffre qu'il faut
comparer aux chiffres aussi annoncés par
la préfecture qui parle de son côté de
27000 manifestants en tout cas selon les
syndicats c'est le signe que la
mobilisation ne faiblit pas bien au
contraire ça a été une journée noire en
tout cas pour pour beaucoup de
Toulousains parce que dès le matin il y
a eu des barrages filtrants dans la
capitale régionale et la circulation a
été très compliquée avec de gros
embouteillages de bon matin pour se
rendre pour ceux qui allaient au travail
ou qui voulaient circuler dans la ville
de fortes perturbations également dans
l'éducation nationale selon les
syndicats il y a eu près de 70% de
grévistes parmi les professeurs des
écoles beaucoup d'établissements fermés
60% de grévistes dans les collèges et
lycées et puis on avait une attention
particulière sur ce qui se passait à
l'université là en revanche il y a pas
eu de blocus de la faculté et puis ça
c'est le cas de Toulouse mais comme on
le dit depuis le début de ce mouvement
c'est aussi un mouvement des petites
villes des villes moyennes et
effectivement les chiffres par le
domaine pour en citer quelques-uns à
Montauban dans le Tarn-et-Garonne il y
avait 20 000 personnes selon les
syndicats hier dans les Russes est
également un record depuis le début du
mouvement de contestation à Rodez dans
l'Aveyron 25000 personnes et puis on a
suivi aussi avec attention ce qui se
passait du côté d'Albi qui avait été
vous vous souvenez il y a 15 jours
l'épicentre de du mouvement national il
y avait tous les leaders syndicaux
depuis le patron de la CGT de la CFDT
Laurent Berger qui était également
présent à Albi et bien hier il y avait
encore beaucoup beaucoup de monde dans
les rues de la préfecture du Tarn avec
22000 manifestants enfin un dernier
exemple qui est un peu symbolique c'est
celui de foi la vie préfecture de
l'Ariège seulement 10 000 habitants
c'est une des plus petite préfecture de
France et bien hier il y avait selon les
syndicats 16000 personnes dans la rue
donc vous voyez en Occitanie la
mobilisation est loin de faiblir bien
bien au contraire avec beaucoup d'impact
dans la vie quotidienne aussi des
habitants de la région et
Eric un mot sur de nouveaux modes de
contestation notamment des coupures
d'électricité oui effectivement donc des
manifestations des barrages filtrants
par endroits des distributions tracts et
puis c'est un peu nouveau il y a eu
aussi des coupures d'électricité géante
plus ou moins revendiquées par les
syndicats alors il y a deux villes en
particulier qui ont été fortement
touchés c'est par exemple Cahors ou le
centre-ville a été privé d'électricité
pendant plusieurs heures mais aussi Albi
ou la coupure qui était pas prévue à
coïncider avec le début de la
manifestation dans les rues rue du
centre-ville c'est tout le centre qui
était en fait privé de courant la mairie
de conseil départemental la lecture ont
été privées d'électricité ça a duré
plusieurs heures l'électricité n'est
revenu progressivement en fin
d'après-midi et il y a eu une deuxième
coupure qui a affectée quand même près
de 30 000 foyers du Nord du Tarn dont
Albi dans la nuit vous voyez c'est
d'autres formes d'action qui touchent
chacun évidemment vous voyez qu'en
Occitanie ça a été un vrai mardi noir on
peut on peut le dire et la mobilisation
reste toujours très forte en attendant
la prochaine journée d'action prévue ce
samedi merci beaucoup Eric mobilisation
record à Toulouse c'est à la Une de La
Dépêche de Toulouse on va à Tours on
retrouve Valérie Pernet bonjour Valérie
merci beaucoup d'être là directeur
directrice départementale adjointe à la
rédaction de La Nouvelle République en
Indre-et-Loire Valérie comment ça s'est
dérouler la journée de mobilisation du
côté tour et dans les autres villes du
département
et bien chez nous ça a été assez
différent parce que la journée a
commencé assez tôt avec une
un blocus organisé sur le site des
Tanneurs de l'Université de Tours ou
encore un barrage filtrant à l'entrée de
la centrale nucléaire d'avoine près de
chez nous mais on peut pas parler de
journée noire sur nos routes ça a été
les deux temps forts et le principal
temps fort chez nous dans le dans le
département d'Indre-et-Loire ça a été la
manifestation organisée hier matin à
Tours elle a réuni près de 11 500
personnes voire 15000 selon les
syndicats ça a été encore une forte
mobilisation mais les records ne sont
pas battus ici à Tours le record reste
détenu par la journée du 31 janvier où
là entre 15 et 20 000 personnes avaient
battu le pavé à Tours mais hier il faut
signaler que et c'est assez inédit chez
nous il y avait aussi des manifestations
dans nos sous-préfectures et là dans les
sous-préfectures la mobilisation a été
plus forte deux fois plus forte que lors
des précédentes actions je peux vous
parler de Chinon où ils étaient 850
alors ça paraît pas beaucoup mais à
l'échelle de Chinon c'est beaucoup ils
étaient 850 décidé au pied de la statue
François Rabelais en fin d'après-midi la
mobilisation a même jugé été à même été
jugée pardon historique par plusieurs
représentants syndicaux qui se référer
notamment au mouvement de 95 avec les
actions contre le plan Juppé à l'époque
et alors dans l'autre sureve actuelle
ils étaient aussi deux fois plus
nombreux ils étaient près de 300 hier
soir c'est beaucoup aussi là à l'échelle
de la ville le journaliste présent sur
place Julia Lucas a remarqué que l'héran
était plus garnis car renforcé par la
présence de quelques gilets jaunes des
enseignants plus nombreux des
agriculteurs de la Confédération
paysanne et même des enfants ils avaient
adapté les slogans et scandés au milieu
des bruits de casseroles Macron t'es
foutu des enfants sont dans la rue alors
chez nous à Tours on a une nouvelle
action une nouvelle mobilisation
aujourd'hui à l'appel du réseau
féministe 37 mais aussi un peu
évidemment avec le mot d'ordre sur la
réforme des retraites donc on attend ça
cet après-midi pour ce point sur la
mobilisation un mot également de votre
opération opération vous lancez dans la
Nouvelle République contre les violences
une femme puisque c'est la journée des
droits des femmes
aujourd'hui c'est une journée symbolique
et nous avons décidé à la Nouvelle
République à la rédaction de La Nouvelle
République d'Indre-et-Loire de nous
engager contre les violences faites aux
femmes d'une journée symbolique à
l'autre tout au long de l'année jusqu'au
25 novembre pour la Journée
internationale pour l'élimination de la
violence à l'encontre des femmes nous
allons consacrer chaque mois une enquête
à cette thématique nous nous engageons à
notre niveau en informant en relayant
les informations nous veillons aussi par
exemple à publier le plus souvent
possible par exemple avec les
comptes-rendus de justice les numéros
d'urgence et les coordonnées des
associations des eaux victimes et le
premier rendez-vous de cette série et à
lire ce mercredi avec l'interview de la
délégué départementale à l'égalité Marie
Roussel qui brosse l'étendue du travail
encore à mener car si la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes a été
déclarée Grande cause nationale en 2018
le combat semble sans fin même si la
représentante des services de l'État
estime qu'en Indre-et-Loire la prise en
charge de haut niveau elle cite que des
agents ont été formés des cellules
d'enquêtes créer que l'accueil a été
melio que l'accueil a été améliorée elle
estime que le maillage est plutôt dense
mais il y a encore beaucoup de travail à
faire et elle a pu s'en rendre compte
avec l'échange qu'elle a qu'elle a eu
avec deux victimes de violences et une
autre femme témoin de violence que nous
avons organisée à la Nouvelle République
et là ce sera à lire demain merci
Valérie et on regardera évidemment tout
ça on regarde la une d'aujourd'hui en
attendant retraite déterminée à
continuer la lutte c'est à la Une de La
Nouvelle République merci beaucoup
Valérie Pernette d'avoir été avec nous
alors pierre et Nicolas les syndicats
voulaient une France à l'arrêt hier
est-ce que le pari réussi
c'est j'aime la question parce que j'ai
écouté évidemment beaucoup de nos
confrères et concerts hier commenter la
journée d'hier et évidemment j'ai
entendu beaucoup d'entre eux allez je
dirais presque parfois se réjouir que le
pari était raté des syndicats parce que
la France n'aurait pas été à l'arrêt
beaucoup d'ailleurs votre invité
précédent Jean-François Copé dans ses
commentaires expliquer que jusqu'à chez
lui il y avait moitié moins de de
grévistes dans cette dans cette journée
de mobilisation
une France elle se met pas à l'arrêt en
un jour donc ils sont un peu impatients
nos amis et collègues confrères concerts
de commenter cette France à l'arrêt
parce que dans trois jours il nous
expliqueront que la France que c'est que
ces grévistes mettent la France en otage
parce que plus d'essence dans les pompes
parce que les transports toujours aussi
perturbés donc ce qui était enclenché
hier c'est une dynamique
militante une dynamique
et qui se renforce franchement quand on
vous écoutez les syndicats euh et je
parle pas de la CGT et quand vous
écoutez monsieur Monsieur Laurent Berger
quand vous écoutez l'INSA quand vous
écoutez est faux j'entends de la
détermination chez les syndicats et la
détermination à aller très loin alors
c'est pas à tous des sites pas d'en haut
il explique hein c'est des c'est des
c'est des des votes en fin de journée
dans chacune des dans chacune des
entreprises mais j'ai le sentiment oui
que ça va ça va durer Nicolas vous
partez sentiments par irrésil hier Paris
réussi oui alors le slogan la France à
l'arrêt c'est un slogan c'était fait
pour mobiliser et pour tenter de
maintenir le même niveau de manifestants
pas être dans dans un phénomène
d'érosion qui est assez classique dans
les mouvements sociaux et là le pari
réussi parce que justement depuis le 31
janvier je crois qu'il y a une
mobilisation qui est quasi constante
hier elle était un peu supérieure à
celle du début donc ça veut dire que
pour les syndicats je vais dire la
gestion le management de ce mouvement
social il est bien fait produit ses
effets et
les résultats sont à leur actifs ça il
faut évidemment le reconnaître après la
France à l'arrêt on verra ce qui se
passe passer par la suite parce que
c'est aussi un moment clé si des
secteurs se mettent à l'arrêt si des
perturbations viennent gêner la vie
quotidienne des Français à ce moment-là
le risque pour les syndicats c'est de
perdre le capital sympathique qu'ils ont
obtenu et qu'ils ont patiemment et
intelligemment construit jusqu'ici et on
sait très bien qu'à partir du moment où
les gens vont se sentir gêner dérangés
et bien ils peuvent se retourner et
l'opinion c'est le le le le capital le
plus précieux qui a pour ce moment
social elle est à un niveau très élevé
un niveau constant depuis le début du
mouvement si jamais il y a des
perturbations qui font que les gens une
partie de la population à ce retourne à
ce moment-là ça sera pour le
gouvernement beaucoup plus facile
d'accélérer de faire passer cette
réforme et puis on verra des phénomènes
de délitement comme on les a vu
d'ailleurs dans d'autres mouvements
sociaux y compris contre les précédents
très formidable
il dit mais c'est s'il y a blocage ça
pénalise les millions de Français qui
travaillent la responsabilité la
première c'est quand même ceux qui nous
gouvernent c'est à dire que gouverner un
pays c'est prévoir et quand ils font ils
s'entêtent sur une réforme qui provoque
le stylité générale la grande majorité
des Français presque 93 % je crois dans
un adoles d'actifs sont contre cette
réforme la responsabiliser d'une
possibilité d'un blocage des effets des
astres sur le monde de l'économie c'est
le gouvernement qui reprend la
responsabilité on peut pas dire on est
pour le droit de grève que c'est
constitutionnel et en même temps
s'étonner que l'instrument de production
est mis à l'arrêt parce que la
conséquence de la grève c'est
précisément la mise à l'arrêt de l'outil
de production donc le gouvernement fait
mine de faire porter la responsabilité
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en France
sur le dos des syndicalistes je rappelle
encore une fois parce que là aussi
j'entends dans les éléments de langage
de beaucoup de parlementaires sénateurs
députés de la macronie expliqué que ces
syndicalistes aujourd'hui seraient dans
une démarche très très agressive ou très
radical qu'ils refusent le dialogue
social mais qui a refusé le dialogue
social sur cette réforme des retraites
si ce n'est le gouvernement le
gouvernement a fait le choix de négocier
et de discuter avec les républicains pas
avec les syndicats avec les républicains
existent depuis le début du quinquennat
précédent souvenez-vous monsieur
Delevoye était chargé des constatations
avec les syndicats ensuite ça a été
monsieur pietrachevski qui a été en
charge des négociations avec les
syndicats on connaît les positions tout
le monde les concertations ont eu lieu
ce que demandent les syndicats c'est
plus de concertation c'est des
véritables négociations les syndicats
ont des propositions alternatives à
faire sur la réforme des retraites parce
que tout le monde est d'accord pour le
fait sur le fait que il y a une réforme
nécessaire à mener sur la question des
retraites et d'ailleurs les syndicats
sont pas d'accord sur les moyens de
mener cette réforme mais aujourd'hui il
y a un blocage un blocage qui fait qu'il
y a une unité syndicale il y a une
opposition massive des Français à cette
réforme et ça s'entend dans la rue et le
gouvernement est Monsieur Attal a beau
jeu de dire c'est la responsabilité des
syndicats si aujourd'hui il y a une
économie
qui va être mise en difficulté mais
c'est aussi par ça qu'Emmanuel Macron
finira peut-être par céder et c'est
hélas comme ça qu'Emmanuel Macron a
toujours fonctionné c'est à dire c'est
il attend il attend il attend d'ailleurs
il est très silencieux c'est pour ça que
les syndicats hier dans l'intersyndicale
l'ont interpellé pour pouvoir être reçus
mais à un moment donné Emmanuel Macron
ne réagira quand il aura le patron du
Medef qu'il l'appellera il y a là il va
falloir faire quelque chose parce que
nos économies elles sont en train d'être
mises en danger donc peut-être qu'à ce
moment-là il finira par bouger donc
c'est un moyen de pression évidemment ce
que vous décrivez là c'est un scénario
c'est pas du tout si ça va se passer
comme ça c'est un scénario c'est le
scénario sans doute que que vous
souhaitez mais la France à l'arrêt pour
l'instant oh la pas vu est-ce que des
secteurs vont causer des perturbations
durables ces prochains jours bah on sait
pas donc pour l'instant on va attendre
avant de juger et puis est-ce que c'est
perturbations vont retourner ou
l'opinion ou le gouvernement c'est
encore moins sûr donc pour l'instant sur
l'effet moi je resterai prudent et sur
le scénario on peut dire évidemment
celui avec mais on peut souvent elle va
crescendo pour pouvoir avoir ce regard
et cet indicateur objectif on les
indicateurs d'opinion que vous citez
c'est exact ils sont ils sont constants
indicateurs de mobilisation constant et
la première mobilisation la mobilisation
la crèche
grosso modo
si on regarde les chiffres de la
fonction publique il y avait moins de
grève dans la fonction publique que des
fois précédente mais c'est intéressant
ça veut dire qu'il y a d'autres
personnes qui se sont mobilisées
d'autres catégories sociales qui sont
allés dans la rue donc voilà on a sur
nous vous êtes impatiente parce que
grévistes et voici imaginez que si on
s'engage dans une grève longue les
grévistes ils ont une organisation et
donc il y a une journée
alors là précision qu'on finale sur des
des petits points de pourcentage parce
que c'est les écarts sont pas énormes
mais s'il y a un peu moins de résidence
la fonction publique le jour les
syndicats appellent à mettre la France à
l'arrêt ça veut peut-être aussi dire
quelque chose peut-être alors si on va
dans votre sens ça veut peut-être dire
qu'ils sont réserve pour les journées et
ça c'est un scénario et pour l'instant
on a une grève pour l'instant on n'en
sait rien pour l'instant on n'en sais
rien mais ça c'est après moi je vous dis
en ce moment même examiné dans
l'hémicycle et hier en fin d'après-midi
c'est l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge
qui a commencé à être examiné et alors
cette nuit on a assisté à une séquence
très politique oui quelqu'un avait
annoncé la fin du clivage droite-gauche
je sais plus trop qui c'était mais si on
le retrouve faudra lui montrer la séance
d'hier tout avait pourtant très bien
commencé il est 19h hier les
manifestants se disperse dans les
cortèges des manifestations le Sénat
entame l'examen de l'article 7 celui qui
prévoit donc le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite la droite défend la mesure
la gauche tire à boulet rouge sur la
réforme
nous y voilà nous y voilà c'est le
Ministre ça fait quatre ans qu'on vous
propose ce type
d'architecture de réforme c'est pas
parce que nous sommes des tétus c'est
parce que nous pensons que c'est le
meilleur moyen de faire en sorte de
pouvoir équilibrer notre système de
retraite si nous voulons le confier à
nos enfants vous avez eu beau menacé le
pays des dix plaies d'Égypte vous avez
eu beau parier sur le fait que les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat des
Français et les empêcher de se mettre en
grève et pour autant ils ont été encore
plus nombreux aujourd'hui qui est
maintenant la question monsieur le
ministre c'est qu'alez vous faire tout
se passe à peu près comme prévu
l'hémicycle divisée en deux en deux car
on le rappelle le groupe macroniste
Sénat le groupe RDPI ne compte que 24
sénateurs sur 348 c'est donc la droite
et le centre c'est à dire la majorité
sénatoriale qui défend la réforme des
retraites ça réforme des retraites
puisqu'elle souhaite apporter des
modifications au projet du gouvernement
mais les prises de parole de la gauche
se multiplient et aux alentours de 23
heures Bruno matériaux et le sénateur
centriste Olivier Hainaut n'en peuvent
plus y décide de contre-attaquer oui
cette réforme nous l'avons déjà voté ici
nos sumo parce que c'est un levier qui
nous permettra de sauver le régime des
retraites c'est un levier efficace c'est
aussi parce que c'est un filet de
sécurité vous enlevez cette borne d'âge
et alors vous aurez une machine à décote
vous nous avez dit plusieurs fois que
nous étions silencieux que nous avions
peur de parler non simplement on a une
obsession c'est celle d'aller au bout du
texte et aller au bout du texte c'est la
responsabilité
alors jusque là on avait un débat très
engagé politique mais sans incident
notable oui fallait pas aller se coucher
avant 1h du matin mais c'est pas pierre
puisque c'est à ce moment là que les
choses se sont accélérées gaucher droit
sont utilisés les outils de la procédure
parlementaire pour se dire ce qu'ils
avaient à dire la droite a des gainé
l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat c'est
un article et bien qui permet de
clôturer la discussion parlementaire
c'est-à-dire de limiter le temps de
parole par amendement ou par article un
orateur pour un orateur compte sur quoi
l'article 38 a provoqué la colère de la
gauche qui a fini aux alentours de 3
heures du matin par quitter l'hémicycle
Patrick canner s'en explique au micro de
Quentin Calmet on ne comprend plus rien
la procédure qui a été lancée on évoque
des amendements qui ne sont pas
distribués
j'ai le sentiment que le président de
l'archet et Bruno retaillod sont rentrés
dans une machine infernale qui est en
train de les dépasser je n'ai jamais vu
ça au Sénat même les plus anciens
considèrent qu'il y a vraiment un
problème majeur sans la gauche et à la
suite de la suspension de la séance le
Sénas ne sait donc pas prononcer sur le
cours le recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite les débats reprendront cet
après-midi après les questions au
Gouvernement ça promet nouvelle soirée
nouvelle nuit peut-être est-ce que c'est
vraiment surprenant ce qui s'est passé
hier dans l'hémicycle du Sénat Nicolas
non c'est pas totalement
surprenant dans la mesure où Bruno
retailleur est prévenu qui voulait pas
que ça s'éternise et puis dans la mesure
où le Sénat prend sa revanche en quelque
sorte sur sur l'Assemblée nationale en
utilisant cet article 38 qui n'existe
pas à l'Assemblée il faut le dire et qui
un article très intéressant parce que il
permet de simplifier considérablement
les débats c'est un article dont
l'éthique de la discussion c'est un
article qui quand même
mériterait d'être étendu sauf que hier
il a été utilisé d'une manière qui a été
vécu et on peut le comprendre de façon
assez brutale par par la gauche qui aura
préféré pouvoir exposer davantage
d'arguments ça sera pas le cas les
arguments de la gauche on les a quand
même beaucoup entendu sur le mode de
financement alternatif des retraites
qu'ils ont proposé depuis le début de la
discussion qui ont tous été retoqués et
donc dans ce contexte là
c'est une façon d'accélérer les débats
et ce sera une façon pour le Sénat de
montrer que par rapport à l'assemblée il
y a bien un vote finale qui aura lieu et
c'est le l'autorité du vote qui est
absolument indispensable en démocratie
on sait ce qu'on veut de fonctionnement
démocratique en France la constitution
des assemblées mais mais c'est bien
l'autorité finale du vote qui doit à un
moment ou un autre être prononcé et on
peut penser que ça sera le cas
effectivement ici au Sénat
oui alors moi j'ai quand même quelque
chose que je ne comprends toujours pas
depuis le début de de cette discussion
que ce soit l'assemblée au cinéma c'est
cette espèce d'obstination à vouloir
être très vite pardon on va demander aux
Français de travailler deux ans
supplémentaires on peut quand même se
dire qu'on a le temps on peut se donner
le temps y compris d'ailleurs sur je
sais pas on pourrait se dire si on a 6
mois de débat parlementaire quand même
sur une question aussi cruciale que
celle-ci et tout le monde a l'air de
dire que c'est normal il faut aller au
vote tout le monde trouve que de toute
façon la seule fonction du député ou du
sénateur ça serait d'aller voter bah non
pardon mais si on croit un tout petit
peu dans la démocratie parlementaire on
croit dans l'écoute des propositions on
croit dans les amendements qui sont
déposés aussi pléthoriques soient-ils je
crois pas en tout cas pour avoir regardé
un peu
les amendements qui ont été présentés
par l'opposition qui y ait eu une
obstruction au point de changer une
virgule et de vouloir faire débattre de
d'amendements et de propositions de de
valorisation du texte qui soit futile
donc je ne comprends pas que on trouve
ça normal que ceux qui ont fait et qui
veulent faire passer cette loi va y
aller très vite parce que il aller à
l'essentiel sur les 64 ans etc ça me
paraît délirant on est dans une
démocratie parlementaire il faut laisser
le temps au Parlement de prendre des
décisions et de coûter tout le monde
donc cette obstination moi me
scandalisent un peu sur ce que l'on fait
de mal à notre démocratie et puis bon on
dit que le finalement que l'Assemblée
nationale était très virulente qui était
très violente avec des députés très très
agités pardon mais la droite sénatoriale
qu'a-t-elle fait depuis le début
d'examen de ce texte si ce n'est de
l'obstruction c'est pas facilité la
tâche du gouvernement que de vouloir
introduire de manière très rapide la
question de la des régimes spéciaux et
d'accélérer sur la fin des régimes
spéciaux c'était pas très malin non plus
c'était son droit mais de vouloir
négocier toujours plus sur la question
des carrières hachées des femmes ça
m'était le gouvernement en difficulté et
puis là sortir l'article un article qui
est de manière sans précédent de vous
pour pouvoir accélérer les débats sur
chacun c'est une manière aussi quand
même de faire un peu de de
mettre un peu de bazar quand même dans
le débat parlementaire donc je trouve
que
à la demande de la gauche datant de la
journée de manifestation pour examiner
l'article 7 est-ce que du coup la gauche
je pense et qu'il a bien compris que
hier soir dans les débats parlementaires
il était plus prudent de ne pas
accélérer les débat de sorte que le vote
se fasse dans la nuit et que demain donc
aujourd'hui à ça appartient à 16h30 au
Sénat les textes et l'ensemble les
amendements seront à nouveau examinés ça
me paraît ça dans un moment aussi tendu
dans un moment de tension que l'on
connaît et que l'on a vu hier à
l'attention moi j'étais dans les
manifestations j'ai bien vu que les gens
étaient manifestés de manière festive
conviviale et chaleureuse avec une
détermination quand même mais
je pense qu'il est absolument sage et
important de regarder chacun des
amendements et chacun des chacune des
propositions qui sont faites sur les
bandes du Sénat il y a pas eu
d'obstruction de la part de la droite au
Sénat il y a eu des disposition qui
était pas forcément celle du
gouvernement mais on peut pas dire
qu'elles ont été de nature à ralentir ou
à empêcher le bon déroulement de
l'examen du texte puisque c'est quand
même ça la définition de l'obstruction
donc on n'est pas dans cette logique là
au contraire le sentiment que que donne
les sénateurs c'est de vouloir rendre
une copie qui soit qui a été votée ça on
vient d'exprimer mais aussi de donner
l'image d'une chambre qui a pu
mener ses débats dans une forme de voilà
de de concorde républicaine même si ça
exclut pas que des moments de tension
bah ça c'est la vie démocratique mais en
tout cas on sent qu'il y a à cœur des
sénateurs de montrer que ils ne sont pas
l'Assemblée nationale et puis si on
parle des principaux concernés
c'est-à-dire la gauche dès le début la
gauche a expiré quai et parce que les
socialistes ici sont sont en position
dominante à gauche que elle aura pas le
comportement de la France insoumise à
l'Assemblée nationale donc je pense que
si on fait un petit bilan à mi-parcours
de la part de la gauche bah la partie en
tout cas la feuille de route a été
déroulée et l'image de d'un groupe qui
se comporte de façon républicaine ils
ont un Concorde de la discussion en tout
cas cette image là elle est acquise et
puis pour la droite et bien aussi des
acquis parce que il y a des choses
qu'ils ont pu apporter au débat enrichir
le texte alors on peut en penser du bien
ou du mal mais en tout cas ils ont fait
leur travail de parlementaire et c'est
plutôt à l'honneur de l'institution on
va parler de la droite on va écouter
Eric cioti puisque hier au grand Berger
a prévenu que les députés Renaissance
qui ne voteraient pas le texte serait
exclu il y a une différence chez les
républicains en écoute le patron du
parti eriki était hier soir sur LCI moi
personnellement je vous le dis je l'ai
dit dès le début on me l'a reproché mais
encore une fois pour moi c'était une
question de cohérence et de
responsabilité je voterai
personnellement ce texte j'invite mes
collègues députés de mon groupe de notre
groupe à le faire après chacun se
détermine en conscience et moi je pose
pas
une vingtaine qui le vote pas
contrairement à ce que vous aurez
demandé ils sont pas exclus bien entendu
que non on n'est pas on n'est pas dans
cet état d'esprit
là on voit la ligne des républicains on
le dit depuis le début les républicains
ils ont la clé de ce texte et de ce vote
est-ce que ce que dit ericsiottif et
prendre un risque au gouvernement de
passer 149-3 oui bien ce texte bien sûr
parce qu'on sait que ces voix qui sont
autour de relais impradié elles peuvent
changer complètement le l'histoire
politique de de ce texte et donc
erisiotique d'en savoir tout l'embarras
qui a du côté des républicains a essayé
de conserver une famille unie alors que
il y a des ambitions personnelles et
puis des un fond
politique ou d'idées politiques et
peut-être un peu différent chez Aurélien
Pradier et donc c'est vrai que si la
droite les républicains se cendrent
encore et ben il restera plus qu'un
micro parti ce qui est déjà un peu le
cas sur le plan des structures
aujourd'hui donc
euh il est obligé il est obligé de de de
jouer cette espèce de rondeur en disant
ah bah c'est pas grave alors que il a
quand même des mises de son poste de
numéro 2 la semaine dernière mais là il
est c'est le maximum qui puisse faire
sinon au-delà c'est vraiment l'existence
même du parti qui menacé Bruno le dit la
réforme qui sera voté si un vote au
Sénat dimanche mini la réforme qui sera
votée sera sa réforme est-ce que du coup
ça va être compliqué pour les
républicains d'autant que leur patron
demande de voter le texte oui bien sûr
après alors parce qu'il faut rappeler la
procédure après la semaine prochaine il
y a une commission mixte paritaire donc
c'est une mini assemblée et un mini
Sénat qui sont réunis cette députés
cette sénateurs pour finaliser le texte
et à ce moment-là dans cette commission
mixte paritaire c'est aussi la droite
qui fera la décision finale en accord
avec la majorité relative du
gouvernement
et donc si ce texte vient du Sénat avec
une approbation massive des républicains
il arrive dans cette commission mix
paritaire il a toutes les chances
finalement de d'être la copie finale
parce que dans cette commission mix
paritaire les représentants des
dissidents LR a priori il peuvent
peut-être y être par une personne mais
peut-être pas non plus c'est pas encore
décidé donc ça veut dire qu'à la fin
c'est quand même la gouvernance et la
direction des républicains qui aura ce
qui tiendra le stylo pierre
on s'est quand même que le que Emmanuel
l'obsession d'Emmanuel Macron depuis le
début c'est de d'éviter de ne pas avoir
à recourir aux 49-3 donc la macronie
s'est mis à genoux devant les
républicains à accepter un nombre de de
projets de propositions des républicains
dans ce texte qui d'ailleurs reviennent
sur les enjeux-mêmes de ce texte comme
Emmanuel Macron l'avais expliqué
c'est-à-dire l'équilibre des finances du
régime des régimes des retraites et ces
ingrats de républicain pourraient ne pas
être assez suffisamment nombreux pour
pouvoir voter favorablement en faveur de
ce texte qui du coup obligé rémanuel
Macron 49-3 donc ça devient un peu
compliqué cette affaire et c'est un peu
ça le le les enjeux ensuite sur les
histoires d'exclusion c'est-à-dire que
le sujet est tellement politique c'est
éminemment politique c'est que je l'ai
déjà entendu ou c'est déjà été difficile
mais c'est comme si on décidait de ne
pas voter le budget c'est à dire c'est
vous êtes pour entre ou contre la
majorité et si vous le savez si vous ne
votez pas le texte sur la réforme des
retraites vous ne faites pas partie de
cette majorité donc j'entends l'argument
des macronistes et en même temps c'est
aussi la démocratie ils sont pas
d'accord sur ce texte mais il y a quand
même beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui
n'est pas d'accord avec ce texte ça j'ai
du mot j'ai l'impression qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne l'entend pas suffisamment et
on va continuer évidemment à suivre la
séance et à parler de cette réforme de
retraite puisque c'est à la une de vos
quotidiens régionaux ce matin on voit ça
avec style
[Musique]
et dans la presse ce matin sans grande
surprise la mobilisation
sur cette journée de manifestation
contre le projet du gouvernement
mobilisation record partout en France
plus d'un million de cent mille
manifestants selon la police 3 millions
500 000 selon la CGT le Dauphiné nous
dit que la rue maintient la pression il
y avait notamment plus de
20.500 manifestants dans les cortèges à
Grenoble La Dépêche du Midi parle elle
aussi d'une mobilisation record à
Toulouse avec plus de 120 000
manifestants dans la ville rose la
Marseillaise se projette quand elle sur
la grève féministe qui aura lieu
aujourd'hui et revient sur les 245 000
manifestants qui ont défilé à Marseille
ce mardi en Normandie à Rouen on a
compté 26000 personnes selon les
syndicats Paris Normandie parle des
véritables marais humaine contre la
réforme des retraites l'autre titre
aujourd'hui dans la presse régionale
c'est la journée internationale des
droits des femmes oui beaucoup de
rassemblements prévus un peu partout
dans le monde aujourd'hui en France le
Journal du Centre pose une question
simple l'égalité c'est pour quand
Emmanuel Macron on avait fait la grande
cause de son premier quinquennat il en a
fait une cause centrale de ce second
mandat mais Elisabeth borne le reconnaît
elle-même il reste encore du chemin à
faire à noter qu'Emmanuel Macron rendra
aujourd'hui un hommage à Gisèle Halimi
icône féministe qui a consacré sa vie au
combat pour l'égalité homme-femme le
chef de l'État pourrait à cette occasion
peut-être s'exprimer sur une éventuelle
inscription dans la constitution du
droit à l'IVG merci Steve les retraites
c'est à dire dans politique
féministe qui s'engagent aujourd'hui
avec la grève féministe on revient
notamment sur une enquête très
intéressante sur le sexisme qui
s'exprime sur les bandes de l'Assemblée
nationale dans ce numéro et évidemment
revient aussi sur tous les arguments qui
montrent combien cette réforme fait
peser de toute de tout son poil
justement la question des retraites sur
le dos des femmes qui en seront les
grandes perdantes justement de cette
réforme Nicolas sur fondamental.fr
nos éclairages sur sur la question des
retraites et à la Une du site la grève
générale son contexte historique son
histoire il faut savoir par exemple que
cette idée de grève générale elle est
antérieure à l'existence des syndicats
elle était exprimée déjà moins de la
Révolution française
merci beaucoup Nicolas
pourrait continuer à suivre la séance à
15h les questions d'actualité juste
après la séance sur la réforme des
retraites peut-être jusqu'au bout de la
nuit évidemment on en reparle demain
bonne journée
[Musique]